Now, back to the potential sources of error--the fact that the earth is a sphere, well we decided
that's not 100% true that the earth is so close to spherical that any error introduced is negligible.
We also decided that the sun's rays don't arrive exactly in parallel and that we're going
to do more about this in the homework, but the error this introduces turns out to be negligible.
Let's talk about point 3--do the sun's rays actually arrive vertically in Syene?
Now to answer this question, let's think back to how Eratosthenes came to this conclusion.
Eratosthenes had come to this conclusion by hearing that if you look down the well,
not necessarily a poorly drawn well, but a well in Syene on the summer solstice
you could see the very bottom--what this meant was that the sun's rays must have been striking
in such a way that a ray which entered the top of the well can make it all the way to the bottom,
and so his conclusion was that the sun's rays are striking vertically.
Now let's see if this is necessarily the case.
Sure, a ray that comes in vertically will make it all the way to the bottom of the well. No problem.
But it's that the only ray that would go from top of the well to the bottom--no.
What about this one--this ray also illuminates the bottom of the well and it comes in at a slight angle.
Now, let's look at what the maximum possible angle could be that allow one of these rays
to enter the top of the well and still illuminate the ground below.
And now it would be this ray, if we try to make this angle any steeper, it wouldn't actually hit
the bottom of the well or it would hit somewhere along the wall.
How can we calculate this angle?
Well let's make some assumptions about the depths of the well
and the width of the well that Eratosthenes was looking at.
Now, I'm no well expert but I'm going to assume that this well had a depth of 40 meters.
Those of you who know more about wells than I do can tell me
if this is a reasonable depth for a well.
I'm going to assume that the width of the well--from this edge to this edge--was about 1 meter.
Now, we have the dimensions of our well.
We have an extreme case solar ray coming down and just barely illuminating the bottom of the well.
Now I wonder, what angle does this correspond to? We know it's not quite vertical.
Using your new trig skills, I bet you can tell me what this angle α is
that this ray is making with the vertical.
Enter your answer in this box, round it to 2 decimal places and remember Google is your friend.